for my ultimate middle-eastern dessert
it's got to be for clever
start by melting butter in a pan chopped
pistachios in a blender
[Music]
then combined with castor sugar and
lemon zest
brush the melted butter around a small
baking tray place half a sheet of filo
pastry on the base brush well with
melted butter
and sprinkle with a pistachio mix repeat
and press down between layers
you're looking to create 30 to 35 layers
[Music]
then cut the back lava into bite-sized
rectangles and bake in a preheated oven
for 30 to 40 minutes meanwhile make your
delicious citrusy syrup simply add water
to a pan along with caster sugar and the
zest and juice of a lemon
simmer for seven to ten minutes making
sure the sugar has fully dissolved now
to give the pakhlava wonderful sweetness
remove from the oven and whilst hot pour
over the syrup so each layer is Flores
Li sticky leaving baklava to absorb the
syrup for at least 12 hours these
delicious sticky trees will keep for a
week but they're so Moorish that we've
done in a flash